messieurs bonsoir installez-vous va le
temps pour moi de donner
une question ou une réaction d'un
internaute du figaro qui nous suit sur
le figaro live et qui réagit sur le chat
c'est pierre qui nous demandent que
pensez vous de l'idée d'une armée
européenne notamment contre certainement
contre je pense que avoir un fonds
européen de défense et mutualiser des
moyens pour des opérations sur des
théâtres extérieurs
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs c'est déjà le
cas dans ces sur certains secteurs mais
avoir une armée européenne tout
simplement qui commande
voilà et donc qui commande on ne sait
pas et et comme au parlement européen je
vois que nous avons des divergences de
vues même aux soeurs de dédé propre
groupe politique avec certains pays
entrés
il y à peu et qui viennent des pays de
l'est si si on laissait faire bien je
peux vous dire que je suis pas sûr qu'on
n'aurait pas des graves tensions avec la
russie donc non je ne suis pas pour
très bien alors donc emmanuel macron
marine le pen en ont pris pour leur
grade lors de la première partie de
cette émission messieurs bonsoir à
nouveau julien bargeton on va les rendre
saint-just c'est à vous monsieur le
sénateur l'europe un rôle à jouer en
matière d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes notamment pour le droit des
femmes
monsieur bellamy a refusé de condamner
la nouvelle législation très durs contre
l'avortement en alabama comment vous
sentez vous vous par rapport à ses
positions sur l'avortement ou d'autres
positions qui peut prendre en matière
sociétale
moi je crois que il faut pas caricaturer
parce que françois-xavier bellamy a dit
très clairement qu'il était pour une
politique de prévention pour que nous
ayons moins d'avortements en france
ce quelqu'un moi j'ai été ministre de la
famille et je vois bien que le nombre
des avortements depuis les années 90
chez les jeunes notamment continuent à
stagner en termes de nombre je crois
qu'il faut avoir une politique de
prévention
ensuite il est favorable à la liberté
des femmes répondent ce moment là il
était d'accord mais moi je les entends
dû répondre à de plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises il est favorable et j'en ai
discuté avec lui il est évidemment
favorable à la liberté des femmes
ci-après à titre personnel dans sa vie
personnelle
c'est peut-être s'il était confronté à
cette situation
peut-être qu'ils n'accepteraient pas
cette situation ça le regarde mais la
politique les positions sont des
positions qui ont des conséquences quand
même des positions qui ont des
conséquences c'est lorsque vous prenez
un engagement de dire mais moi si je
suis élu je vais mettre en place une loi
qui qui mettra à mal la loi simone veil
s'est absolument pas le cas
il l'a dit il l'a répété donc n'allez
pas chercher des choses là où il y en a
pas c'est pas le sujet franchement aller
on s'ajuste marano moi je suis
heureux d'être là parce que je voudrais
qu'on puisse parler de sujets européens
est confronté vraiment nos points de vue
ce qui n'a pas été vraiment fait dans la
campagne jusqu'à maintenant il faut le
dire c'est un peu regrettable mais enfin
bon c'est comme ça et là je voulais vous
interrogez avoir votre point de vue par
rapport à des votes que votre groupe que
vous même que les parlementaires
européens français ont été mis au
parlement européen pendant la précédente
mandature parce que j'ai vu des
contradictions avec votre programme
actuel avec le programme de monsieur bel
et bien lors par exemple le 16 février
vous avez voté pour une résolution je
crois pour mettre à profit le potentiel
du traité de lisbonne afin de mettre en
place un système juridique et législatif
contraignant pour la répartition et la
réinstallation des migrants en europe et
vous avez même aggravé votre vote
c'est ça c'est moi qui parle le 15 mai
2010 est pour le soutien à la
relocalisation des migrants alors je
parais eu assez mauvais pour la
politique française
ça me paraît contraire au programme de
monsieur bel ami à l'heure actuelle et
j'aurais voulu entendre vos explications
sur ce ils votent que vous avez monsieur
valéry je vais vous dire une chose c'est
que moi je suis très attaché à faire la
clarté sur mes votes à travers les
explications de vote que je publie à
chaque séance à chaque fin de séance
plénière donc tous les français qui nous
écoutent qui veulent savoir ce que j'ai
voté et pourquoi j'ai voté de telle
manière peuvent aller sur le site du
parlement européen tapez nazis morano
ils trouveront toutes les explications
de vote en super ce que je vais pas
rentrer sur un tel un vol d'un tel
invoque parce que sinon sur les vols sur
l'ensemble des votes de nadine morano
par le vote du groupe des députés
français de retrouver oui c'est nadine
morano vous avez en face et moi son
valet que je rentre dans les votes qui
ont été faits par le front national
notamment qui n'a pas voté
l'augmentation du budget de frontex qui
est il
qui est nécessaire pour sécuriser nos
frontières extérieures on ne s'en sort
pas donc telle est votre vision quelle
est la mienne
moi je vais vous dire une chose c'est
quelque chose qui nous différencie
vraiment d'abord comme vous le savez je
les dis surtout si tous les plateaux et
dans notre programme nous sommes très
clairs nous sommes absolument déterminés
à stopper l'immigration illégale qui est
sur notre territoire
d'accord donc pour ça nous contrairement
à vous puisque nous avons voté les
moyens pour renforcer l' agence frontex
pour avoir plus de dix mille gardes
côtes pour sécuriser nos frontières vous
avez voté contre mais je vous dire
monsieur v les rangs il ya bien il ya
plus important que ça on sait très bien
que si on ne fait rien s'agissant de
l'afrique où moi je suis membre de la
délégation aux charge des relations avec
le parlement panafricain au parlement
européen et donc moi ce que je dis c'est
que tous les bateaux qui viennent en
provenance de l'afrique ont vocation à
repartir vers le continent africain la
solidarité la solidarité non parce que
monsieur salvini lui il est pour la
répartition des migrants ce que moi je
ne veux pas il a il a refusé les bateaux
tant mieux il a refusé les bateaux qui
arrivent en italie mais lui ce qu'ils
demandent c'est la répartition des
migrants moi je ne veux pas la
répartition une grande je veux
l'expulsion des migrants arrivés en
situation irrégulière je veux que les
bateaux qui sont venus en provenance
d'afrique repart vers l'afrique parce
que la solidarité n'est pas uniquement
dû à l'honneur vous revendiquez il a une
position plus radicale que celle de
monsieur salvini donc annoncé c'est un
bien sûr oui parce que monsieur selvini
lui devrait partir les migrants dans les
pays l'union européenne moi je ne le
veux pas je veux que ceux qui veulent
venir sur le territoire européen non non
non écouter monsieur monsieur chauffeurs
des jeux vous plaît c'est la réalisation
de monsieur monsieur la rente saint-just
je voudrais que ceux qui nous écoutent
pas ce que vous allez dire j'ai voté
sans jamais moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que c'est les français qui nous écoutent
ils ont accès à des moyens d'information
vous pouvez passer de joueurs renvoyés
sur votre chute morano points comme à
sepa morano points communs
non c'est non non excusez moi non mais
je suis bien non le coach de notre
édition de recherche à moi non mais
n'allez pas dans ce que nous ne sommes
pas je vous dis très concrètement je
suis candidate à cette élection
européenne
je suis pour la maîtrise des frontières
extérieures je suis plus que ryu le
conditionnement
nous conditionnons nous aide à l'afrique
puisque nous donnons 17 milliards
d'euros chaque année pour le
développement de l'afrique et je
considère que le citoyen européen n'a
pas à payer deux fois une fois pour le
développement et une fois pour les
clandestins qui sont des leçons les
radars je te rappelle en vie dans cette
voie donc je veut conditionner nos z à
la mairie de retenir les migrants à la
maîtrise la capacité agricole
immigration corps parce que je vais vous
dire il ya un grand danger qui nous
guette parce que là la vague migratoire
qu'on a eu à connaître c'est pas grand
chose mais certains veulent inscrire
dans nos textes
le ladino disposition de réfugiés
climatiques
donc après l'asile politique l'asile
économique l'asile médical on va se
retrouver à voir un asile climatique
mais là je peux vous dire que là ça va
être portes ouvertes et on ne va plus en
sortir c'est déjà compliqué maintenant
sortir et je suis contre cela on peut
changer aussi peut-être même qu'on peut
les battre
etc vous savez que nous on souhaite
refonder schengen pour tout simplement à
la fois pouvoir accueillir ceux qui le
peuvent ce qu'ils le doivent
mais surtout aussi que l'europe assure
sa souveraineté sur ses frontières et
notamment en renforçant l'agencé frontex
avec dix mille personnes en plus et et
et surtout éviter que ceux à éviter et
éviter que ceux qui écrivent vite et que
ceux qui contrôlent pas leurs frontières
continue à le faire parce qu'il faut
aussi dire qu'il ya des pays où 20% font
diablement commandé un corps de
fonctionnaires de 10000 à des frontières
aussi éloignés que les pays frontaliers
que les préfets qui sont là on le sait
bien question c'est chez l'autre
vous soutenez monsieur montre de webber
pour prendre la tête de la commission il
est proche des conservateurs autrichiens
dont on a vu d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
enfin hier le scandale dans le
gouvernement autrichien avec la
proximité à la russie et qui souhaitent
délocaliser le siège de strasbourg
est ce que ça vous pose une difficulté
de soutenir ce candidat conservateur qui
d'ailleurs ne parle pas un mot de
français monsieur le sénateur je vous
signale que la fin l'alliance
enfin aux sociétés on sait pas parce
qu'on ne sait rien d'où vont siéger ou
vont siéger les députés en marche on
s'aperçoit du programme hockey vous
allez faire un groupe progressiste pour
moi pour l'instant si vous voulez les
personnes avec lesquelles que monsieur
macron lorsqu'il est venu au parlement
européen a reçu il a reçu les députés du
groupe alde et est donc avec monsieur
verhofstadt qui lui est un des plus
virulents a demandé à ce que le siège du
parlement européen soit à bruxelles et
non plus à strasbourg on était quand
même toit ben non mais vous avez été
clair ben moi je me suis aussi
moi je considère que le siège du
parlement européen est d'ailleurs ça
devrait être l'unanimité ce que ça l'est
ce que ce que 6 ou est-ce qu'ils parlent
discutent pas d'autre candidat européen
attendant dans les faits les français
sont pour
généralement les français sont pour
maintenir le siège au parlement européen
ça pourrait se discuter parce que comme
vous le savez on se réunit que quatre
jours parce par mois au parlement
européen mais moi je considère donc de
discuter vous le remettez en cause un
match disputé
pourquoi il les autres pays le discute
c'est parce qu'on ne se réunit que
quatre jours par mois mais moi je
considère être un jour
parce que la réalité c'est que le siège
européen à vocation non pas être à
bruxelles mais que tous deux prêté ma
patrie c'est bruxelles qui doit
déménager à strass mais bien sûr c'est
ça la réalité parce que la capitale
européenne
et c'est dans notre programme et c'est
ce que nous avons dit avec leurs ventes
y est c'est que la capitale européenne
c'est strasbourg c'est strasbulles sur
la commission nommée ne connut fallait
l'éloignement est un problème quand même
la matériel pour vous le vivez
d'ailleurs vous maintenez justement moi
je le vis au quotidien
non mais vous avez d'une part
l'institution parlementaire et donc
l'institution parlementaire à vocation
est réuni sur un même site
imaginez vous si vous aviez l'assemblée
nationale qui siègent quatre jours à
paris et le reste du temps qui sera lyon
un moment vous vous direz ça serait bien
d'avoir tous au même endroit
et bien moi je considère et nous
considérons parce que c'était le départ
et c'est comme ça que ça a été créé que
le siège du parlement européen doit être
à strasbourg 7 septembre
il faut il faut aider à voir plus de
moyens à strasbourg parce que vous avez
des parlementaires quand beaucoup de
difficultés à arriver à strasbourg parce
que vous n'avez pas de lignes
internationales comme vous pouvez en
trouver à bruxelles donc là il ya des
moyens m pour que strasbourg offre plus
de possibilités mais un argument la
capitale avait eu lieu en faveur de
strasbourg c'est que c'est la ville de
la paix en europe puisque c'est elle qui
a été libéré par leclerc et que c'est là
où les derniers combats contre les nazis
ont eu lieu au faux pas ne faut pas
oublier sa vie mondial c'est aussi d'art
dans là ville mondiale de la tête c'est
ainsi verdun oui mais le centre mondial
de la paix se trouve à verdun bien mais
bon oui vous avez raison ça sent ça
c'était la garde encore une fois sur des
questions un peu de fond et je pense que
là vous allez voir est un effet sur des
fonds
vous expliquer sur le pacte de marrakech
madame morano d'inviter tous a toujours
en boucle un le pacte de marrakech n'a
jamais été examinée au parlement
européen c'est donc je vais toucher coup
vous avez toujours voulu le pacte de
marrakech et oui je suis bien d'accord
mais bon tu as envie d'elysée jamais
avait il va parler les schémas exposer
ma question et vous me critiquerait
juste après donc le 18 avril 2018 tous
les élus de votre groupe
sauf vous des ja et vous pourrez si vous
voulez bien nous expliquer cette
solitude et la contradiction que je vais
pointer ont voté pour une résolution en
faveur de la poursuite de l'élaboration
du pacte de marrakech donc vous vous
voter contre tous vos amis votre peau et
dans le programme de monsieur bellamy
s'est dénoncé au niveau européen le
pacte de marrakech proposition numéro 11
alors pourquoi n'avez vous pas voter
vous cette résolution est pourquoi il ya
telle une telle contradiction entre ce
que vos amis et votre groupe sur vous on
fait dans la précédente mandature et le
programme de monsieur bel habit alors
d'abord pour être très clair vis-à-vis
de ceux qui nous regardent et qui nous
écoutent jamais le pacte de marrakech en
tant que tel en tant que texte c'est
parce que j'ai dit mais moi je le
précise quand même qu on a été amené à
être voté non mais a été à elle n'a été
votée au parlement européen ni même dans
les assemblées nationales d'ailleurs
d'accord j'aimerais bien voilà donc il y
avait des résolutions moi je lis toutes
les résolutions
il y a des chapitres ou des paragraphes
qui peuvent me déplaire et donc j'ai
voté contre
après chacun a su mêler mes collègues
n'ont pas voté pour le pacte de
marrakech
ça n'existe ils ont été voulus une
résolution terme qu il mettra sioniste
non mais je vais vous dire alors n'allez
pas caricaturer parce que je caricature
mais oui mais bon je vous je vous
explique et j'explique à ceux qui nous
regardent tous mes collègues
d'abord ne sont pas du tout des
immigrationniste ils sont sur la même
ligne que moi qui est de lutter contre
l'immigration illégale qui est de mettre
qui est que ceux qui veulent demander
l'asile chez nous le fassent dans des
hotspots sur le continent africain
lorsqu'ils viennent du continent
africain et pas sur le continent
européen
comme le veut la règle en ville en
marche non mais voilà donc c'est ce que
nous faisons depuis le départ en
renforçant d'où les moyens de son côté
l'impression qu'on vous dépouillent là
ça a toujours été comme ça en valeur
surtout pendant les périodes électorales
c'est à dire de l'est républicain l'ump
avancera a toujours prôné le répéter à
lectra repris notre programme mais là
c'est ce qui se passe dans cette
campagne électorale puisque je vois
proposition numéro dénoncée au niveau
européen le pacte de marrakech vous amis
ont fait exactement le contraire il ya
un an en avril 2010 huit mois mais on
est en campagne
non mais nous sommes en campagne
électorale ça joue la corde et vous êtes
va être content parce que si vous dites
qu'on est que vous êtes des pouilles
aimons ce qui me concerne jamais eu peur
de parler des questions migratoires sans
langue de bois et avec beaucoup de
vérité et en même temps vous êtes en
même temps rhabiller vous devez être
content parce que la république en
marche et si le front national
aujourd'hui est aussi haut
et à chaque fois que le front national
ce que j'appelle pardon hein le parti du
raj oui le rassemblement national
de quoi le ce que j'appelle le parti du
ras-le-bol
c'est à dire qu'en fait je rampe chibli
je rencontre beaucoup de gens qui nous
disent ah bah non mais moi j'ai voté le
rassemblement national
pas parce que je prends marine le pen
mais parce qu'il en a marre et qu'il
faut à vous envoyer un avertissement
monsieur macro donc en fait les gens
veulent pour villa alors le chalet c'est
les gens qui votent pour vous ils votent
contre
ils votent pas pour rien ne bouge pas
tout mais il voulait mépris j'ai pas
trop aimé moi je vous les connaissez
bien des yeux
pardon je ne maîtrise jamais les
citoyens quels qu'ils soient mais au
contraire je les invite à regarder de
près votre programme puisque moi j'en
d'une scène ce soir vous êtes d'accord
sur les migrations
on est d'accord sur l'immigration mais
on devrait tous être sur l'immigration
mais on devrait tous est d'accord sur
une migration moi je ne supporte pas
l'immigration illégale
et j'ai pas besoin d'être au front
national ou de renier ce que je pense
parce que on n'a pas le droit de parler
d'immigration laisse que l'immigration
et a été éteint une problématique qui
doit être qui doit être réservé au front
national je ne crois pas je sais que j
allais chez entrer tout le monde pendant
ces cinq ans dans le temps je pensais
n'importe quoi c'est une chose est sûre
d'une chose est sûre la famille le pen
prospèrent sur la misère des français
depuis des années sans rien proposer
sans rien proposer de sera posée de
choisir de choses crédible et ça s'est
vu d'ailleurs jean la présidentielle de
le manque de crédibilité de madame le
pen a été évidemment aux en totalité vie
n'en voudra pas on a le sentiment que
j'la - crédit on a le sentiment que la
que la votre liste nommé pas l'écologie
en priorité contre avons la nôtre vous
savez que nous avons un certain nombre
de propositions de la banque européenne
du climat ou la taxation du kérosène ou
encore ne pas ouvrir des négociations
commerciales avec les états unis tant
que l'accord de paris nul ne leur met
pas en oeuvre
quelles sont vos propositions en matière
de transition écologique
moi vous savez je pense que l'écologie
se doit se vivre au quotidien sans qu'on
culpabilise en permanence et sans
contact sans carla que je dis je viens
proposition d'accord mais je dois quand
même de faire une phrase bien sûr bon
sens que mon taxe aussi les gens moi
j'ai j'appartiens à la commission
industrie au parlement européen nous
avons pris beaucoup de mesures notamment
sur l'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments
je crois que nous devons aider aussi et
même si on considère que c'est pas
quelles sont vos propositions là pour
l'avenir puis va vous parler de ce que
vous avez fait comme l'eurodéputée
sortante
mais qu'est ce que ne faisait pas
frappant ce qu'il ya sur l'écologie non
c'est pas frappant mais enfin je vais
vous dire c'est pas frappant non plus
quand vous parlez des agriculteurs que
monsieur macron écrit sa grande lettre
là à tous les citoyens européens en
ayant passé 14 heures au salon de
l'agriculture
alors que le budget du parlement
européen le plus important de lecture
non mais c'est pas ça
à la question environnementale sénateurs
non monsieur non parce que
l'environnement c'est aussi
l'agriculture de sur le sénateur
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais simplement vous
dire que quand j'ai vu cette tribune
rédigée par monsieur macron où il n'y a
pas un mot sur l'agriculture à tous les
citoyens quand bpa sur vos propositions
du écologie mais si sur l'écologie même
si c'est pas le coeur de notre sujet
nous le coeur de notre sujet parce que
l'écologie le coeur de l'écologie de ma
tête dans toute personne honnête c'est
comme au coeur du d'accord de l'or et
vous savez ça doit être dans toutes nos
politiques dans la vie quotidienne
parce que quand je voit l'hypocrisie qui
consiste à dire qu'il faut changer de
véhicule et que tous les véhicules
diesel vous savez où ils partent les
véhicules diesel mais via véhicules
diesel
monsieur le sénateur ils partent en
afrique et quand on fait croire que la
police passion opposition avec pretty
sure que la pollution ne traverse pas la
méditerranée ça me rend leur formation
non d un million d illustrations qui a
proposé en vain que l'on s'assure que
tous les problèmes ne se ressemblent pas
dans ce reproche
voilà photo ec à bercy mercier s'est
terminée voilà c'est bien voilà vous
aviez encore d'autres votations non mais
je savais ce que vous êtes un grief côté
nos programmes sur l'australie la
nouvelle zélande madame manon séguin
merci encore monsieur voit la dernière
partie l'audition publique maintenant
avec orianne mancini et brigitte boucher
qui font leur entrée sur ce plateau
[Musique]